[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a este programa de radio
francia internacional y de france 24 el
comercio electrónico ha experimentado un
auge sin precedentes desde que comenzó
la pandemia las restricciones han tenido
como consecuencia que la gente recurra
cada vez más a comprar por internet el
comercio electrónico tiene sus ventajas
pero también plantea muchos problemas
para hablarnos de ello hoy hace escala
en parís la abogada colombiana ángela
cubillos angela muchísimas gracias y un
placer tenerla otra vez en nuestros
estudios y asad y aída por la invitación
usted mismo usted es especialista en
economía digital en la tendencia ya era
al alza pero la pandemia de coronavirus
la ha acelerado compramos por internet
mucho más que hace un año en
latinoamérica en cinco años se ha pasado
de 126 millones de compradores a más de
267 millones
destacan dos países méxico y brasil
donde la progresión ha sido espectacular
porque estos dos países despuntan
yo creería que principalmente porque son
las dos grandes digamos potencias
económicas de américa latina brasil está
en cabeza con un 35 por ciento de
crecimiento desde que inició la pandemia
y méjico con un 25 por ciento si no me
equivoco colombia por ejemplo por su
parte también tiene un porcentaje de 27%
28 es porque las empresas tuvieron que
recurrir a otros medios para poder
incrementar y encontrar los canales de
venta y entonces yo considero que la
respuesta sería que como se tratan de
economías tan importantes esto hace que
ellos estén peor están también en este
modelo de negocio hay un elemento
esencial que es el algoritmo que es un
algoritmo cómo funciona y compramos
realmente lo que queremos comprar o lo
que quieren las empresas vender
si el algoritmo es la base de cualquier
tecnología no solamente del ecommerce es
la base de la inteligencia artificial de
la block sainz cualquier tecnología
necesita un algoritmo un algoritmo es un
proceso un proceso es la descripción de
un proceso como por ejemplo lo hacemos
con una receta de cocina como la receta
de y seguidamente hacemos ponemos este
ejemplo que es el de la receta de las
tortas de manzana entonces está la
descripción y es esto ha sido definido
como la descripción de un proceso pero
igualmente como la descripción o la
solución a un problema la solución a un
problema pero los algoritmos que se han
abordado desde la época del siglo 17 por
el filósofo life in its que decía que no
solamente es la descripción de un
problema porque eso sería únicamente la
automatización sino que igualmente esto
incluye un razonamiento lógico y ese
razonamiento lógico es muchísimo más
complejo de lo que nosotros vemos
nosotros vemos el algoritmo por fuera
porque no tenemos acceso a toda la
descripción del algoritmo
sabéis que están protegidos por el
secreto empresarial de las compañías y
es justamente un debate jurídico muy
importante que se está dando porque
necesitamos entender realmente y tener
transparencia sobre la forma como estos
algoritmos funcionan porque estos
algoritmos como lo ha dicho por ejemplo
lawrence lessig en su artículo sobre el
codis lou se vuelven la norma es la en
los algoritmos se convierten en la
normativa digital son sistemas
normativos paralelos al sistema jurídico
que son actualmente importantes y que es
importante que tengamos esa conciencia
porque es algo que usamos todos los días
que realmente son los que rigen el
internet en las reglas de internet son
unas reglas que no están reguladas por
el sistema jurídico y que tienen una
influencia importante sobre nosotros
porque como tú preguntabas justamente
ellos si te pueden tener influencia como
en el libre arbitrio de una persona y
dirigirte
compra según si los productos
exactamente porque el algoritmo está
fabricado de forma que permite y es un
estudio que justamente estuve realizando
sobre como por ejemplo la inteligencia
artificial puede influenciar la toma de
decisión de una persona porque empiezan
a identificar los gustos o empiezan a
proponer unos contenidos digitales que
pueden orientar al consumidor
a una cierta dirección oa un otra oa una
tendencia política oa otra entonces es
importante que tengamos conciencia del
uso de esto porque podemos tener si una
vez tenemos esa conciencia podemos saber
que tenemos también que intentar ir
encontrar su web el libre al vidrio en
realidad es una ilusión y no solamente
estamos condicionados por los algoritmos
schopenhauer ya lo definía y lo decía y
espinoza decía que el libre arbitrio
justamente es una ilusión porque
nosotros
no estamos
sientes de las y no solamente el aspecto
evolutivo y no de las causas que nos
conducen a tomar esas decisiones
condicionadas entre los algoritmos de
estas cookies no tan pesadas no porque
muchas veces vas a comprar una cama y al
cabo de unos días te siguen apareciendo
esas publicidades de cámaras no es
inquietante y puede ser hasta peligroso
no es inquietante y es justamente algo
que yo quisiera como poner de relieve
para que los utilizadores tengan
conciencia que si es gratuito un
servicio somos nosotros el producto las
cookies se instalan en nuestro
computador y hacen una trazabilidad de
todo lo que nosotros revisamos en
internet esto crea un perfil de
consumidor y a partir de ahí es este
producto que esa utilización que
nosotros tenemos gratuito como por
ejemplo de 'tik tok' de instagram
finalmente van a proponernos esos en los
usos gratuitos pero en realidad eso lo
que nos va a conducir es a
aquí nos van a orientar y nos van a
proponer una publicidad dirigida de
acuerdo con los usos que nosotros
tengamos dentro de la plataforma claro
porque ya casi no hay fronteras no entre
las redes sociales las plataformas de
comercio electrónico no es justamente
porque existe un modelo de gratuidad
aparente si es gratuito somos nosotros
del producto y eso sí lo más importante
a retener porque el modelo de gratuidad
de internet que es el modelo que más
funciona es un modelo bifaz tiene dos
fases entonces este modelo es un modelo
económico que fue creado por ya antiguo
un premio nobel de economía francés que
define que existen dos mercados que se
encuentran entonces de un lado estamos
nosotros los utilizadores que creemos
entrar a una plataforma gratuita una
aplicación gratuita y estos estos
nosotros dejamos ahí nuestros datos no
estos datos nosotros vamos a pensar que
en este mercado es de aparente gratuito
no va a pasar nada pero existe otro
mercado paralelo que es el metro el otro
mercado pertinente que la empresa va a
dirigir y en este mercado aparece en
este mercado pertinente él va a
monetizar estos datos y es acá donde nos
van a enviar toda la publicidad dirigida
que las empresas ya conociendo cuáles
son nuestros gustos van a poner
proponernos directamente a nosotros
entonces es importante saber que en las
cookies las cookies es un dato personal
que permite identificar el bergantín
cable una persona y nosotros como
titulares de sus datos tenemos derecho a
suprimir las cookies del computador y
solicitarle a la persona que las tiene
la supresión o mirar dentro de nuestro
computador porque existen herramientas
para suprimir las o no aceptarlas
digamos que no estamos obligados a
aceptarlos en principio esta privacidad
de los datos preocupan muchísimo uno de
los últimos debates últimamente si
quedarse o no en whatsapp
o pasarse a otros sistemas de mensajería
como telegram u otros el que ha cambiado
con las nuevas condiciones de whatsapp
que pueden hacer con nuestros datos se
puede escapar a esto y creo que europa
la excepción
es un tema muy sensible porque es un
tema que afecta justamente el derecho a
la intimidad de las personas las
comunicaciones privadas jurídicamente
están protegidas y es prohibido que una
persona que ofrece un servicio de
comunicación pueda publicar sus datos
porque eso está sancionado por cualquier
ordenamiento burladés o no cambia eso no
cambia
el tema es que justamente vuelvo al
modelo de gratuidad whatsapp tiene un
modelo de gratuidad y ellos necesitan
monetizar su aplicación entonces han
encontrado una solución y es proponer un
whatsapp profesional es el whatsapp
profesional obviamente que va a cambiar
las condiciones porque los clientes de
whatsapp profesional van a proponer hay
productos a los consumidores y estos
consumidores van a otorgar unos datos
entonces los los acá cambia la
organización y el funcionamiento de la
aplicación porque estos datos obviamente
ya no van a ser alojados ahí sino que se
va a realizar como una monetización de
los datos
una política expresa para la utilización
con fines profesionales entonces yo no
podría decir que hay que cambiarse a
otra aplicación porque pues eso no me
concierne a mí pero lo importante sí es
tener esa conciencia de que se trata de
un dato que es de carácter privado y que
debe continuar manteniéndose como
privada cuando dice monetizar los datos
de qué datos estamos hablando estamos
hablando en whatsapp profesional de los
datos de consumo hay plataformas
actualmente por ejemplo de a las
personas van a un supermercado y para
cómo está el tema 'el hobbit' no pueden
tener la misma persona que se ocupaba de
ellos para asesorarlos personalmente
entonces a través de whatsapp para ver
una persona que lo va a orientar para
poder elegir el producto más que más le
conviene y estos datos entonces ahí les
van a enviar una política de privacidad
que viene dentro de whatsapp para
determinar si la persona acepta o no
después continuar recibiendo ofertas es
lo con el whatsapp profesional con el
whatsapp normal con el whatsapp normal
yo
pero que acá se aplicaría en la
protección a la vida privada y es un
dato personal que está prohibido
normalmente pero el tema acá es muy
importante también tener en cuenta y es
que whatsapp pertenece a facebook
entonces el whatsapp como no está
monetizando no le produce ganancias a a
facebook entonces ellos quieren conectar
los dos servicios y es lo que sucede y
la discusión más importante que existe
jurídicamente en temas de derecho de la
competencia actualmente es que son
gigantes de internet que proponen bari
en varios mercados pertinentes varios
servicios diferentes y entonces es
difícil poder desmantelar cada uno de
esos servicios y lo que debería hacerse
y que ya se ha hablado en la unión
europea es establecer una separación
entre cada uno de los mercados por
ejemplo google es motor de búsqueda
propone también comparación de precios
servicios de geolocalización y
realizando esto pueden realizar
visión de
de otros concurrentes entonces es cómo
dividir cada servicio para poder
establecer que a quién hace qué y
realizaron pedir vueltas también
precisas sobre lo que hace para uno
bueno muchísimas gracias ángela cubillos
abogada y especialista en comercio
electrónico gracias y muchísimas gracias
a todos ustedes por habernos acompañado
ya saben que nos pueden seguir en
internet en rf y mundo.com y en france24
punto com hasta pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]